[Music]  you don't know what you're missing  you got no losses guillermo del toro  calls for hollywood to hire more women  the shape of water director was on stage  at the Critics Choice Awards Thursday  night accepting Best Picture for his  film and ended the show with this  rousing speech for everyone that has  been in equal in working with women if  you do that you don't know what you're  missing at the Golden Globes just a few  days earlier he told ET the vibe of the  season I think is becoming really  powerful and I'm hoping because I'm  seeing genuine desire for change genuine  the that is landmark year that night  Toro won Best Director but Natalie  Portman made this quip as the nominees  were announced and here are the all-male  nominees some said her comment was too  harsh though Thursday del Toro explained  why he didn't mind listen what this  season install does is it's time for  everyone to say what they think so let's  do it  [Music]